[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport spécial
était aujourd'hui nous ferons le bilan
de cette saison sportive dans les
yvelines à ces parties a pour le
sommaire est respectives coup de
projecteur sur les plus grands moments
de cette saison 2018-2019 ryder cup
coupe du monde de cyclisme sur piste
record tour d'horizon sur les
rendez-vous qui ont marqué à cette année
rugby à versailles a peut-être réalisé
l'une des plus belles grandes saisons de
son histoire le club a terminé la saison
invaincu dans le championnat honneur et
montera en fédérale 3 nous recevrons des
joueurs est intelligent dans ce set 8
sport agenda en fin d'émission coup de
projecteur sur les rendez vous qu'il ne
faudra pas manquer cet été ou à la
rentrée christophe manas le dtn de la
fédération française sera notamment avec
nous pour nous parler du tour de france
et des championnats de france de
cyclisme sur piste
le sport est blinois c'est maintenant
sur tv 78
[Musique]
on commence donc cette émission spéciale
était par les moments forts qui ont
rythmé cette année à 2018 2019 de la
ryder cup au golf national à une manche
de coupe du monde de bmx au vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
tour d'horizon de l'actualité sportive
du département
un montage signé romain aarhus fini une
semaine fantastique une grande
expérience pour tous les spectateurs
et puis voilà en plus à la fin c'est
l'europe qui gagne donc c'est génial on
peut partir sans tous émus bah oui oui
ça c'est c'est c'est la fin d'une
histoire mais méhaignerie
[Musique]
quelques regrets on était à domicile on
espérait
peut-être avoir des résultats des
milieux résultat on a tenté
plusieurs de nos sportifs sont sortis
assez rapidement
dans les manches de qualification donc
quelques regrets
[Musique]
malgré tout il avait fait planer ce n
est pas ce que vont aborder ce match là
pour par le remporter
on n'a pas remporté ce match mais je
tiens à saluer le courage l'abnégation
et le coeur que mes joueurs ont mis sur
ce match
[Musique]
et sont plus grands plus costaud plus
lourd feu rapide plus vive
ils sont 60 sur le banc de
avéo couche en fin de match mais ça m'a
fait travailler cet intéressant
cependant je pense que je serai en
trajectoire de balle
après on n'a pas questionné qu'on
appelait puissance été facile on a fait
un bon match dans sa globalité et j'ai
trouvé ça super intéressant
lendemain de cette affaire
[Musique]
je prends ce n'est pas non plus leur vie
assez les mecs mais technique
technique se déplacer
[Musique]
c'était très plaisant de gagner
aujourd'hui aussi d'obtenir le maillot
jaune
ce sera sympa de le porter ce maillot
jaune demain aujourd'hui c'était une
étape très dure avec beaucoup de vent
mais l'équipe a fait du très bon travail
avec qui est six coureurs dans le
premier groupe
[Musique]
il ya beaucoup de choses qui bougent à
côté et stoppe donc seul inscrit c'est
difficile c'est fini j'ai pas aux
grandes capacités pulmonaires donc j'ai
joué ma force de volonté
[Musique]
la magie du quidditch c'est pouvoir
mélanger plusieurs sports pour autrui
renouveau et après on est sur des
manipulations de balles sur du dodge
ball à on admire américain on est sur la
même manipulation du ballon de volée
[Musique]
on récupère cette première place qu'ils
ont occupé les trois quarts de l'année
ça fait vraiment plaisir tout le mérite
en revient aux joueurs au staff au
sikkim en un qui m'accompagne la
direction qui m'a fait confiance cette
année est vraiment fier aussi de
terminer meilleure défense de la ligue
de paris
[Musique]
énorme tatouage au championnat de jumet
seeker impressionnant tous les atouts
qui font
ça me donne des idées
[Musique]
que la compétition approche qui
s'agrandit pour iliad effervescence donc
c'est bien pour nous ce positif les
enfants ils sont pleins d'énergie donc
on en prend c'est bien
[Musique]
c'est toujours valorisant d'être sur un
terrain de
de faire partager ce que c'est ce qui
nous a permis de gagner pas mal de
titres
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les français étaient là à crier encore
et encore et je me suis dit faut que
j'aille pop geste et j'ai poussé dans
les bols s'est passé c'est juste
incroyable d'avoir gagné ici quand on
voit ces images on se dit que l'année
2018 2019 a été exceptionnel dans les
yvelines un mot de rugby à présent eux
aussi ont été exceptionnelles je veux
bien sûr parler des rugbymans du
rugby-club de versailles ils ont terminé
premiers de leur poule dans le
championnat honneur
invaincus ils ont emporté le titre de
champion ile-de-france pour nous parler
de cette très belle année nous recevons
sur ce plateau le responsable
communication du club pierre chevalier
ainsi que trois joueurs lucas bateau qui
rodolphe et chaput et charles landon
bonsoir est-ce que vous at on dit à une
année exceptionnelle pierre chevalier
dans ces grandes mesures non ont même
même dans notre dans nos perspectives à
trois ans puisque lorsqu'on est arrivé
avec une nouvelle équipe pour aider
l'ancienne équipe dirigeante c'était
juste après la descente de fédérale 3 en
honneur
il ya trois ans et on savait qu'il
fallait il faudrait du temps pour
remonter pour préparer un certain nombre
de choses et mettre mettre en place la
structuration du club et notamment à
travers la formation et et le fait de
faire monter les plus jeunes en équipe
seniors mais de là à arriver à une
saison quasi parfaite parce qu'il aura
manqué il aura manqué finalement un
titre à la première un titre à la
réserve éventuellement à titre national
puisqu'on a eu les deux titres régionaux
imaginez une saison aussi idyllique avec
les seniors invaincu en match de poule
la réserve qui me parlent qui ne perd
que deux matchs deux titres régionaux
la réserve demi finales du championnat
de france et la première qui tombe en
16e de finale
donc ça on n'aurait jamais imaginé une
saison aussi aussi enthousiasmante
dynamique est quasi parfaite du
qu'est-ce qui a fait la différence cette
année par rapport aux autres années
à votre avis je pense que le groupe on
est avant tout je pense une bande de
copains avant d'être une bande de
coéquipier voilà après enfin il ya eu
des moyens qui ont été mis en place il
ya quand même un gros investissement qui
a été donné par le bureau à la fois on
va dire dans toute l'organisation la
structure et les fonds financiers et
aussi un gros travail met en oeuvre par
nos deux enfants nous en tout cas moi je
prends pas la première mais d'autres
deux entraîneurs respectifs
voilà après moi je pense que vraiment
aujourd'hui on montre qu'on a une bonne
une bonne bande de copains et je pense
que la différence s'est faite là-dessus
sur la solidarité
on était prêt à mourir pour le copain et
je pense que ça n'avait pas forcément ça
avant à versailles rodolphe vous
confirmez je touche y en a qu un monde
puis on a vu aussi un petit peu la
pression du glay livre de vote c'est sa
très belle bande de copains comme on dit
dans le rugby c'est les valeurs de
l'ovalie
non mais c'est surtout qu'on avait un
peu la pression début de saison parce
que c'était la dernière des trois années
que le bureau s'était fixé pour la
montée en fédérale 3 l'année dernière on
était content de notre saison parce
qu'on fait un bon parcours en
championnat de france mais il manquait
un petit truc donc cette année on
s'était dit s'était dit qu'il fallait
monter on s'était donné l'objectif du
titre et dès le début de saison amis
quand même un mulet s'est mis les moyens
pour y accéder donc on avait la pression
là on a voulu on a voulu réussir ça qui
on y est on y arriver quoi
charland on voit qu'ils avouent rigoler
entre vous sur le plateau vous rigolez
entre vous à l'extérieur même un peu un
peu trop peut-être
d'après mais vous êtes également sérieux
aussi sur le terrain comment j'ai fait
pour pas vous démobilisez quand on voit
une saison comme celle-là qui se profile
très très bien
quand vous êtes invaincus au bout d'une
dizaine de jours n'est sûrement vous a
été pour rester sérieux je pense que
c'est ça aussi il faut savoir avec les
objectifs qui étaient fixés en début de
saison
savoir rigoler en dehors et être sérieux
pendant les matches et donc voilà je
pense qu'on a mis le nécessaire après
voilà on a toujours des déceptions les
deux titres de championnat de france qui
était possible aller chercher en b on
perd en demi-finale en première on
s'arrête en seizièmes des boutiques
étaient qui était serré est prenable
porter parce que c'était pas trop facile
à un moment pierre chevallier bons
joueurs ont peur on peut pas dire on ne
peut pas dire ça parce que sur le sur le
papier le certes la poule la poule dans
laquelle était le rcv par rapport à
l'autre poule d'île de france était plus
abordable sur le papier par contre
c'était loin d'être gagné d'avancé
la victoire je pense que on y prend goût
dans cette aventure de potes et cette
aventure de humaine qui est ou qui aussi
intègre le cuivre le collectif ultra
versailles et notre kop de supporters
il ay ay ay justement cette cette
motivation et la quête de la performance
conçu très bien mettre en place les deux
staffs de la première et de la réserve
on a quand même eu des oppositions assez
sérieuse pendant toute la saison et le
fait qu'on s'arrête en gros en 16e de
finale par exemple en première contre le
rc vesoul
sur un match on s'arrête quand même sur
un match nul 23-23 on perd aux tirs au
but ce qui était donc vous restez un vin
que tout est vrai qu'on reste en plus
invaincus 6 a en gold exactement le côté
un petit peu subjectif de la chose mais
mais cela son pôle et 7,7 cette saison
il fallait bosser il fallait être là aux
entraînements il fallait il fallait
enchaîner les matches certes c'était
c'était devenu une habitude de gagner
pas une routine une habitude de gagner
mais de toute façon largement pas facile
et surtout pas couru d'avancé au début
de la saison il ya du coup ce petit
bémol en championnat de france flux k
way dire des contre contre vesoul web
aux tirs au but pour être essentielle
c'est rare en plus la principale de ce
match pour vous la faire voilà je pense
que vraiment faim comme vous dites comme
a dit pierre la routine de gagner sur
des moments comme ça à couperet où c'est
un match et après c'est terminé en fait
je pense qu'on s'est mis une pression
supplémentaire que vous n'avez pas
forcément et je pense qu'on a peut-être
pris ce match est un peu trop à la
légère en disant voilà façon déjà
championne de france on est déjà revendu
qu on n'a plus rien à prouver à personne
on a fait nos preuves cette année si on
perd tant pis laventure sera belle et je
pense que on sait mais justement ce
leitmotiv la en tête et je pense qu'on
aurait dû vraiment un petit peu joué
deux faces de façon libérée de dire que
voilà deux façons
on connaît nos forces après on est tombé
sur une très belle équipe de vesoul mais
je pense que vraiment on aurait pu on
aurait pu faire mieux on aurait pu aller
au moins au moins en quarts de finale
comme on l'a fait l'année dernière
charles l'objectif l'année prochaine ça
sera quoi l'objectif moi je ferai plus
partie de cette très belle équipe mais
l'objectif je pensais d'aller viser le
haut de tableau de fédérale 3 on a joué
les clubs qui ont surmonté l'année
dernière notamment sarcelles notamment
ont d'autres clubs que j'ai pu en tête
qui ont joué des phases finales en
fédérale 3 cette année
du coup pourquoi pas faire la même chose
l'altercation on vous avait parlé du
cube pierre chevallier
est-ce qui vous ont aidé d'être à
versailles et dans cet avion dans cette
aventure humaine c'est un élément
déterminant que l'on est par exemple que
l'on n'avait pas dans le dans le scope
au départ quand on a quand on a relancé
vendredi mais le projet sportif à trois
ans de remonter c'est un c'est un projet
qui était en gestation et qui met mais
qu'il n'existait pas réellement et ça a
été mais au delà de toute espérance en
termes de en terme d'animation
d'ambiance puisqu'il faut savoir faut
savoir en gros qui nous ont suivis à
domicile d'abord mais surtout aussi à
l'extérieur y compris sur certains
matches un peu clé des juniors dont des
u18 il était là et ça a créé une
émulation un dynamisme fantastique et
d'ailleurs ça a mené un monde
armand ne font en tribune que moi il ya
une dizaine d'années je n'ai absolument
pas connu à part chantelle et ça le
chapeau peut être tiré de grandes
manière j'ai la montée on était presque
400 kg de vous couper pendant des heures
et des heures
on vous regarde quand même encore un
petit peu avec nous quelques instants va
refermer cette page versailles par un
tour d'horizon sur les clubs de la cité
royale
et cette année 2018 2019 a été
exceptionnel là encore en football le fc
versailles 78 a terminé à la deuxième
place du classement de nationale 3 à 4
petits points seulement du champion les
gobelins et de la montée les joueurs de
youssef chibi termine la saison avec un
bilan de 13 victoires 7 nuls et 6
défaites
en basket là aussi grosse saison pour
les clubs de la cité royale chez les
féminines le lcv 68 les filles ont
terminé troisièmes des phases finales du
championnat de france de nationale 3
elles ont été battues en demi-finales
par nantes un résultat qui leur permet
d'accéder à la nationale 2 chez les
garçons l'équipe d'olivier patins
terminer champion des play-offs 2
re et national après avoir remporté la
finale contre le paris basket sur le
score de 92 à 60 le lcv 78 va accéder à
la nationale 3 l'année prochaine
une réaction autour de cette table
qu'est ce qui fait que inverser ça gagne
lucas je pensais déjà au fond on a des
très belles infrastructures à versailles
je pense que tout est mis en place pour
qu'on soit qu'on évolue dans les
meilleures conditions possibles je pense
que ça aide énormément
voilà après maintenant talbot c'est une
volonté je pense de la part de la mairie
aussi on nous en a souvent parlé
versailles a c'est une visite culturelle
on nous a aussi beaucoup dit que ben il
fallait un peu diversifiée les points
forts de la ville on voit bien comme ou
pas comme disent très bien duquel les
infrastructures nous rugby on a un
terrain synthétique tout neuf on a un
terrain parfait sur l'herbe ou voit tout
les toutes les salles toutes les salles
dans versailles a le foot qui à montbron
enfin il ya comme des infrastructures
magnifique les moyens sont là qu'à un
moment il n'y a pas de raison que ça
suive pas quoi dire j'ai très rapidement
françois de mazières nous l'a dit quand
on continue à redire de verfeuil pour
fêter là pour fêter la montée viennent
certes versailles est une ville
culturelle comme le rappelait or dolf
mais c'est une ville de sport dans
beaucoup de sports elle est performante
et la ville investit justement pour ces
sportifs et pour les familles
versaillaise merci à tous les cas d'être
passé sur ce bateau continuera
évidemment vous suivre l'année prochaine
dans le championnat de fédérale 3 après
a les meilleurs moments de cette année à
dans les yvelines je vous propose
maintenant les flops sportif dans le
département et oui il ya eu quelques
déceptions dans les yvelines
en football américain pressenti pour
aller en d1 les templiers d'elancourt le
montrons pas cette année favori la
rencontre ils se sont inclinés en
play-off de 2e division les élans
courtois ont été battus par les
gladiateurs de la queue en brie en
demi-finale de conférence 15 à 10 et
s'incline à ce niveau pour la deuxième
année consécutive une vraie déception
pour le club qui végète rats en deuxième
division pour la quatrième année
consécutive notre deuxième flop concerne
la boxe et plus particulièrement marvin
petit l'élan courtois perdu pour la
deuxième fois de sa carrière le boxer
surnommé le gitan s'est incliné aux
points face aux belges francesco patera
en février dernier en belgique
il ne devra donc pas à champions ebu hop
est un des poids légers cette année
depuis à marvin petit n'est pas remonté
sur un ring
notre troisième flop concerne le
handball masculin plaisir n'apparaît
6 a réalisé une bonne saison en
nationale 3 les plaisirs oies qui avait
accédé à cette division en 2017 ont
connu une année compliquée les joueurs
de victor garrigues et l'ont remporté
que six victoires en 22 matches disputés
des résultats qui n'aurait pas été
suffisant sur le papier pour se
maintenir le club termine 10ème sur 12
mais réussit tout de même à se maintenir
in extremis dans la division suite à un
repêchage
une mesure qui va permettre à plaisir de
conserver ses meilleurs éléments et
surtout à ces jeunes une information à
football à présent l'entraîneur de
trappes hicham et redit ne sera pas là à
la rentrée un an seulement après son
arrivée il a décidé de quitter le club
qu'il vient de faire monter en régionale
2 pour raisons personnelles
hicham azerty sera remplacé sur le banc
par ludovic que gauthier ex coach de
l'équipe b de versailles la reprise pour
le club est fixée au 12 août
on passe maintenant à notre page agenda
[Musique]
un mot de baseball à présent les cougars
de montigny le bretonneux n'auront pas
de vacances cet été les joueurs de
rodolphe émergeront pendant les deux
mois de compétition leur objectif
accrocher une finale dans le championnat
de france pour faire aussi bien que la
saison dernière on écoute l'un des
joueurs de l'équipe pas sylvain perrin
au micro de tv 78 on a mal commencé avec
leur corps à sanaa régulière mais après
je pense qu'on peut faire le tout
possible pour arriver jusqu'en finale en
une jeune équipe on a été très soudée
penchard langer la coupe d'europe
malgré notre effectif réduit et là je
pense que si on a l'effectif est au
complet on peut faire de bonnes choses
encore une fin de saison haletante à
laquelle qui abriel do carmo va
participer lit qu avec les cougars de
montigny le bretonneux le catcheur de 24
ans originaire du brésil est aujourd'hui
considéré comme l'un des meilleurs
joueurs du championnat de première
division
nous lui avons posée à trois questions
[Musique]
j'ai commencé le baseball gras saint lô
perdre mon frère mon demi-frère sainte
famille japonaise il faut déjà penser
france au brésil
du coup mon frère elle a commencé à
jouer au baseball y avait 6 ans moi
j'avais fait on j'ai commencé à jouer
avec lui
j'aime accroché direct
[Musique]
non c'est le sport c'est que j'aime bien
que tu peux être bon tout seul vingt
neuf joueurs victoire c'est fin son
bureau où sont les sports collectifs
tu peux être bon tout seul mais si ton
équipe et le pas avec toi derrière toi
tu peux rien faire il est nécessaire
[Musique]
mon objectif cette année c'est d'arriver
en finale avec montigny pauvre qualifié
prenez le prochain pour la coupe
d'europe et voilà avoir moins de 16 ans
et faire des bons trieurs maintenant sur
le fait que j'aime vraiment et j'ai
toujours depuis le début je suis bien
mais après ici
zone 3 clubs il y aura du baseball cet
été dans les i dans le département mais
également du cyclisme deux grosses
compétitions sont programmés cette année
à dans les yvelines et le tour de france
passera par le département le dimanche
28 juillet prochain le peloton
s'élancera depuis à rambouillet autre
rendez vous le championnat de france de
cyclisme sur piste qui se déroulera au
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines à la mi-août
pour nous parler de ces ados rendez-vous
christophe manas directeur technique
national à la fédération française est
avec nous bonsoir bonsoir
alors on va commencer par le tour de
france c'est un plaisir toujours de le
recevoir dans les yvelines
ben tout à fait là on parle de la
dernière étape là on n'en est qu'au
début du tour et commence d'une manière
excellente avec la victoire de julien
dallas philippe aujourd'hui est le
maillot jaune
donc il nous reste une vingtaine de
jours pour aller jusqu'à cette dernière
étape des partira dans les yvelines donc
plein de belles choses j'espère dans
l'intervalle ça sera pas forcément la
course la plus spectaculaire j'ai
rétabli généralement la dernière étape
et tu n'auras dire une un peu un défilé
souvent
les choses vont se jouer jusqu'à la
dernière et enfin l'avant dernière étape
qui se passera dans les alpes et de
classement général sera en principe figé
à partir du samedi soir et le dimanche
c'est un défilé devant le public donc et
puis surtout une étape qui se joue
généralement au sprint sur sur les
champs-elysées qu'est ce que ça apporte
au cyclisme évinois l'organisation d'une
telle compétition
le tour de france ait un plus grande
course du monde
à voir la dernière étape c'est à voir
c'est le jour de fête c'est vraiment
dans un tour de france il ya des rendez
vous il ya le grand départ donc ça c'est
important la cette période qui espace
les deux trois premiers jours là c'était
la belgique qui a une grand départ après
il ya des moments clés des étapes
alpestres dans les pires années ces
étapes de montagne puis le compte à
monture un contre la montre là aussi à
pourchasser des étapes clés et puis la
dernière étape ça reste le un peu le feu
d'artifice final le moment un peu de de
célébrations et c'est une belle chance
on va parler du parcours par où on va
peut passer un peu le ton c'est un des
parents ouvriers des départs rambouillet
arrivée sur les champs elysées je n'ai
pas complètement étudié le parcours là
également je crois par la vallée de
chevreuse également oui ça ça va être
facile à les yvelines sont vraiment un
très beau département de cyclisme sans
chauvinisme on peut dire c'est le plus
bel envoi de l'île de france si on voit
d'ailleurs que tous les cyclistes de
villes de france vient de rouler samedi
le dimanche sur les routes de chevreuse
donc le tour de france passera par là je
vous dis pour se défiler vers vers paris
vers les champs-elysées c'est peut-être
aussi sur des routes qui seront
peut-être celle du des jeux olympiques
l'an 50 donc en connaissance tout le
monde alors un peu plus tard du 10 au 17
août il y aura les championnats de
france de cyclisme sur piste
est ce que c'est un rendez vous
important pour la piste alors oui c'est
là en plus important de l'année
au niveau national c'est évidemment le
rendez vous le plus important de l'année
les pisteurs français en catégorie
sprint d'arrivée discipline du sprint
sont parmi les meilleurs coureurs du
monde
donc là au cours de ce championnat de
france va nous aurons tous les tous les
meilleurs
pistards français au départ donc c'est
une grande semaine de compétition qui va
commencer par les catégories cadets
juniors sur les premiers jours et puis à
partir du mercredi et qu'on valide
jusqu'au samedi donc un grand
rendez-vous de cyclisme de haut niveau
télévisée tous les tous les après-midi à
partir de à partir du 15
il y aurait qui par exemple sur la piste
alors tout le tous les coureurs de
l'équipe de france françois pervis greg
baugé caleyron vigier et la halle et
puis notre championne française mathilde
deux groupes
est ce que tout le monde peut venir
assister à cette nuit les dissonances et
c'est on espère 4 mille environ 4000
spectateurs sur la durée de la semaine
l'entrée sera gratuite au vélodrome mais
c'est vraiment un spectacle de très haut
niveau qui sera proposé je vous dis avec
les catégories jeunes sont la première
partie de la semaine et puis des élites
à partir du mercredi
merci christophe manas je le rappelle le
tour de france passera par les yvelines
le 28 juillet prochain et les
championnats de france de cyclisme sur
piste se dérouleront à la mi-août du 10
au 17 août au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
on continue à cet agenda la saison
2019-2020 s'annonce une nouvelle fois
chargée dans les yvelines en plus de la
reprise des différents championnats le
département va accueillir de grands
événements nous vous proposons un top 3
des rendez vous qu'il ne faudra pas
manquer en montage de jus la grande
ville la saison 2019-2020 s'annonce
riche en sport dans les yvelines voici
notre top 3 des rendez-vous qu'il nous
faut pas manquer
[Musique]
la saison reprendra par l'un des
événements majeurs du golf français
l'open de france cette 103e édition sera
une nouvelle fois organisé sur le
parcours de l'albatros du golf national
de saint quentin en yvelines
petite particularité cette année
l'événement qui se déroulait fin juin
était dépassée à l'automne par
l'european tour nous 17 20 octobre les
meilleurs joueurs européens
participeront à cette compétition créée
en 1906 pour l'instant aucune star
mondiale n'a confirmé sa participation
[Musique]
il y aura également du cyclisme dans les
yvelines la saison prochaine la course
au soleil bahrini sera organisée une
nouvelle fois dans le département pour
la onzième année consécutive le peloton
s'élancera depuis une ville yvelinoise
au mois de mars après saint germain en
laye en 2019 et chatou en 2018 quelle
ville organisera la première étape de ce
rendez vous la réponse sera donnée au
plus tard en janvier 2020 l'année
dernière le hollandais dylan un gros
navet guen s'est imposé dans la dernière
ligne droite
[Musique]
enfin à la rentrée les amateurs de
course à pied vont se donner rendez vous
ce dimanche 29 septembre à 10 heures
pour la 42e édition du paris versailles
cette année près de 25 mille coureurs
vont une nouvelle fois s'élancer depuis
la tour eiffel pour arriver devant le
château de versailles en passant par la
redoutable côte des gardes à meudon
au total 16 km sont au programme si vous
voulez participer la liste des
inscriptions est ouverte
on termine par une information insolite
une star du football a choisi les
yvelines pour partir quelques jours en
vacances david beckham l'ancien joueur
de manchester united et du real madrid
était au début du mois de juillet au
château de versailles que sa femme
victoria pour fêter leurs 20 ans de
mariage ils ont pu passer quelques
moments privilégiés tous les deux en
couple en privatisant les lieux les
yvelines un département que david
beckham connaît bien puisqu'il a joué au
paris saint-germain en 2013 et s'est
entraîné au camp des loges de saint
germain en laye
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve on se
retrouve à la rentrée dit s'il a passé
un bel été sur tv 78
[Musique]
il